there are ways to curate your life so
you get the best from these forms of
tech without having to just accept the
bad stuff that comes along with them and
i think that's the key goal here that's
certainly my goal i don't want to turn
my back on tech
i want to embrace it fully but in
embracing it recognize what it's doing
that's negative
do you know anyone who doesn't wish that
they spent less time
on their phone not many people
um you know it's funny when i when i
speak about this
and it's been a while but when i'm in a
room with people and i ask them a
question
i often begin the the event by saying
all right i want to get a sense from 1
to 10 from all of you
how do you feel about your phone use
well one is i'm completely happy i
wouldn't change a thing it's only
brought
joy into my life makes my life better
it's enriching my experiences blah blah
to ten it's destroying my life so that's
the spectrum
and i asked them to close their eyes so
they're all doing it individually and
they put their hands up at one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
and the vast majority of people give a
score between a six and a nine
out of ten which says that they feel
that the phone has done a lot of
harm it's brought a lot of damage so
there are some people though you watch
them you say one you start at the number
one
they'll be like you know if you've got
200 people in a room there'll be a
couple of hands that go up at one
and i'll often ask them afterwards not
usually on the spot but i'll say to them
tell me about your use your phone use
and they'll say things like
i'm in tech i know i'm unusual this way
but i've got a lot of systems in place
i'm very careful
it's never people who are like i just
happen to stumble on a perfect way of
using my phone these are people who are
serious about what they're doing so
there are a few people but not many
so you need the weaponry to be able to
fight back
you need the systems in place i think
the the word systems is so critical with
phones because they
they do everything they can to dismantle
whatever self-control resources you have
and the only way you can fight back is
by having habits and systems
that that mitigate that uh help you
overcome those many many attempts from
from tech companies to
to circumvent those systems what are the
most
common systems that you see people
come up with is there a common thread
between them
um yeah people sometimes talk about
having kind of
wishy-washy rules like i will try to do
this or try to do that that never works
it's really hard to go by those rules
it's like dieting that if you if you say
i'm going to try to eat less
of you know less chocolate i'll only
have three of these little kind of
pieces of chocolate instead of five or
ten that's really difficult but if you
say i'm not gonna have chocolate that's
often doable
so i find that people who do the best
are um
they're pretty firm like they'll say
things like um dinner time
is completely phone free for me there's
no way i'm going to change that rule i'm
never going to have any flexibility on
that rule
i could be home alone i could be out
with friends i could be
no matter what context when it's when
i'm eating dinner there is no phone
involved there is no tv
involved and those people seem to
succeed and i know it's hardline
and some of them do have flexibility and
they'll say you know i'm going to make
an exception
but generally speaking i think having
those really firm hard and fast rules
works well
and that that's just one example but but
generally having a very firm rule and
establishing a habit i think is really
important
in this domain i would agree the best
strategy that i've ever had has been
keeping my phone out of my bedroom i
know that you've mentioned
uh previously that you try and do that
um but it is
such a it's like a multi-faceted way to
wreck your day like you can wreck
tomorrow before tomorrow's even begun
that's true yeah it's true and i do that
frequently unfortunately i mean i try
very hard with my phone
i live in in the us my family's in
australia so it's you know it's ten
thousand miles apart
and um i'd say once a year there's a
phone call that comes in at the middle
in the middle of the night
and i feel like that i want to be able
to answer that call when it comes in
you know maybe once a year is an
exaggeration maybe once every two or
three years
but it's enough that it weighs on me and
so i've decided that a bit of
flexibility on this rule is justified
so i'll go for six months with the phone
out of the bedroom and then i'll get one
of those calls in the night and then for
three months i'll keep the phone in the
room and then i'll go back to
being willing to you know i think the
thing that you realize when you study
this stuff
is um theory everything's really easy
you can deal with all these things with
with solid ideas and you can say you
know i'm going to be hard and fast about
this
um and then in practice it's often much
more complicated
like i i want to know when my family's
calling me from australia whether it's
at 3am or
7am or 10pm or whatever it is and so
that makes that rule more difficult to
follow
but i try that's the
sort of the crux to probably what a lot
of today's conversation is going to be
about
that there are particular things which
occur
objectively on one side of the phone
there are particular goals
objectively which you want to achieve on
the other side of the phone but then
there's like the phenomenological
experience of
being a user of a device and that's
where everything kind of goes out the
window
yeah i think that's right i think um you
know if you describe what a phone is
to people in say the year 2005 two years
before the iphone was introduced
it's not that long ago it's like 16
years you know it's a decent amount of
time but it's not a huge amount of time
i think the idea that the phone would
change everything for everyone it would
be something that you'd be getting
notifications in the year 2020 or 2021
saying you've been on your phone on
average
for six hours a day and that that's not
unusual people
would have said that's crazy i mean what
that there's no way that's going to
happen
and and then when you actually use the
device you realize how compelling it is
and how hard it is to resist
um so you're right i don't think it is
the kind of thing that
until you're actually in the midst of
using it you don't get the full sense of
just how
how much time just ebbs away it's it's
incredible what are some of the
psychological hooks and techniques
that you looked at what are some of the
tools that are being used
there there are many of them um the
there are a few really big ones so one
of the big ones is variable reward
um so it's basically getting rewards
from the device that
makes it a lot like a slot machine a lot
of people have used that metaphor to
describe it
that the the phone is a slot machine
that delivers jackpots every now and
again
and it might be in the form of a an
email that you get it might be in the
form of
you know you post something on social
media you get this great flood of
positive feedback people are reposting
retweeting regramming
you know some famous person picks up a
tweet and suddenly it goes viral and
thousands of people are commenting on
the thing you said you know that's a big
flush of positive feedback
but it's unpredictable and it's got to
be unpredictable because if it were
predictable
and you knew when the rewards were
coming they were the same size every
time the same intensity
we'd lose interest humans and basically
every other animal as well
are very sensitive to variable rewards
so those are baked in
goals are another one humans very goal
oriented and other animals are too to an
extent but
we focus a lot on round numbers the idea
of having a thousand likes a thousand
follows all that sort of stuff
those metrics matter in ways that are a
little bit silly
um i remember i think i talked about
this in the book
um i remember running a marathon my
first marathon
which was a decade ago and i remember
how
focused i was on those round numbers you
know like the idea that uh
that a 329 was materially different from
a 331
but that a 327 was about the same as a
329
makes very little sense but it was so
compelling to me like if i didn't get
under 330 or if i didn't get under four
as it happened the marathon went worse
than planned if i didn't get under four
i was gonna be in a lot of trouble so so
these goals are another big part of
what the devices do and they'll they'll
reward you they'll turn experiences into
games
you know like even inbox zero this idea
of getting to the end of
conquering the game of email every day
that's a problem as well
so goals variable feedback and then
there's a big part a big part of it is
social
so you know like the there's there's a
sense of
i know in a lot of communities when
people are saying
and in a community on instagram for
example and you all
whether it's a sporting community like
an athletics community or whether it's
you know you're all entrepreneurs or
you're all academics or whatever it
might be
there's a sense that you should support
other people and they should support you
and once that becomes a part of the kind
of norms the etiquette of
behaving that way online you feel bad if
you don't
like people's posts they feel bad if
they don't like yours and that really
gets its hooks into you
the same way i think a lot of the big uh
massive role-playing games
like world of warcraft you play in
guilds with other people you're on
teams and so there's this huge social
element it's like going to war
virtual war and if you if you suddenly
decide one day you're not going to show
up
that doesn't really fly so i think
that's a big part of it the fourth one
that i'll just mention briefly that i
think is
is perhaps the most powerful is the
eradication of stopping cues
which i i've really researched pretty
deeply
and it's this idea that you know there
are two things to getting people to use
your product
one is getting them in the door so
interesting them saying to them hey you
should try this thing
but the second thing that i think we
often overlook is once they're there how
do you keep them there
and one way you do that is if you
prevent
the the mechanism that says to them you
should probably move on to something
else from
from activating you short circuit that
they'll just keep doing what they're
doing
so the endless scroll of facebook
instagram twitter
emails just keep coming there's this
idea that they're like zombies you kill
them all at the end of the night
you wake up in the morning and they've
all resurrected you've got more of them
in your inbox
the endlessness of of all of these
different um
different platforms i think makes it
very hard for us to resist them and so
once we're into them
there's no bottom to the news to what
people are sharing with you to what
what you can learn online and i think
that's a big part of it too
wasn't there something the guy who
created infinite scroll am i misquoting
this did the guy that created infinite
scrolls say it was the biggest regret of
his career
yeah yeah i've heard that too yeah
i think i you know it's it's as a
business move
it's genius it's one of the one of the
smartest most
powerful that and the like button why
why
well because you've turned something
that's asymmetric that's just a way of
sharing things that i'm feeling into
something that becomes a bilateral
conversation
so the like button when facebook
introduced it before the like button
you would go onto facebook to learn
about what your friends were up to
so if i if i've moved to a new town or i
have a new job or
i've got a new girlfriend or whatever
that's something i'm going to post
online and i'll tell you that
and then you on the other side of the
screen say that's interesting and then
you move on with your day
but i as the person who posted that
don't get any feedback as soon as you
have the like button
everything's bilateral it's a
conversation so i say i have this new
job and then you say congratulations on
your new job i like that you know give
the thumbs up
and and that engine for feedback that's
where the whole thing gets social that's
where the social
requirements start to come in that's
where the variable feedback comes in
if you can get a like why not get 10
likes or 100 likes or a thousand likes
and then you suddenly got a new form of
currency and and there's a you know
people talk a lot about these studies
showing that when when teens
see likes accruing on their instagram
posts their brains look a lot like the
brains of drug users who are injecting
drugs
and i i think that's blown out of
proportion but i think what's true there
is
that it's a reward it's a genuine reward
it may not be real currency like money
but but the the sense that other people
appreciate what you're doing online
is it's powerful it really it drives us
on
what are some of the bases for why these
are so effective
honestly what is it about variable
schedule rewards
that actually make them so compelling
like what why is there a [ __ ] in
our source code our genetic source code
that allows that to be slotted in
i think you can tell a lot of stories
about these kinds of mechanisms like
especially for variable rewards
um if you if you imagine being a human
you know tens hundreds of thousands of
years ago in
you know the evolutionary past and
you're going out and roaming the
savannah and let's let's be really
um cliche about it you're roaming the
savannah looking for
whether it's food or whatever it is if
you were the if
your ancestors were the ones who went
out and said you know every 100 days i'm
going to catch a bison
and that's going to feed me for days and
days it's going to feed my whole tribe
i'm going to be a hero everyone's going
to
applaud and whatever um
if if your ancestors were the ones who
said i'm going to do that i know it's
only going to happen
infrequently but when the jackpot comes
it's worthwhile it's going to sustain me
you keep going despite not winning over
time you keep going you keep going out
there and you keep showing up there's
value to that there's evolutionary value
if you if there are no one has these
ancestors because we're the ones where
the products are the ones who kept going
but there were some who probably went
out there and said it's been 50 days
i'm just going to eat some berries and
it didn't work out for them so well
over time so i i think over over time
the traits that were embedded in those
people the way they responded to these
kinds of cues
are now expressed in us because they
survived and we're the we're the result
of that
i think that's one story you could tell
um
but in general just persevering i think
a lot of this is about persevering that
that if the reward is totally
predictable you know what size it is
um there's certainly some value if the
reward is significant enough to coming
back over time
but if it's a it's a potentially huge
reward that's
a long tail reward it happens very
infrequently but when it does happen it
changes your life
you want to be around for that um and so
that has a different kind of quality to
it it's like the jackpot quality in a
casino that's really what drives people
on
they're all kind of imagining this
barely attainable but possible slightly
possible
slimly possible really big reward i
think that's what drives them on
have we mapped what would have been our
um evolutionary status hierarchy
of wanting to have reciprocal altruism
wanting to have this sort of sense of
belonging and that we're moving up the
ladder
is that what's now being quantified in
terms of the objective metrics that we
see is that where the hack comes in from
the social side
yes i think so i think you can now say
i can tell you within one like how i
feel about a post i'm i'm saying
i but in general a person can you know
if you're i'm not really
i don't use these platforms much um
i don't use instagram at all but
you know if you're someone who generally
gets 10 likes
and then you get 20 likes on a post that
has an effect
we know that has an effect it does feel
like a reward it feels like you're
slightly higher up the hierarchy
if you're someone who for a while is
being followed by 100 people
you post something it goes viral and
suddenly a thousand new people follow
you
that also feels like a jump up the
hierarchy whether that's illusory or not
doesn't actually matter
what what it means is that it feels like
a genuine currency your brain and your
your
psychology responds as though it's real
and as a result you keep coming back for
more
that's what these platforms care about
what the the creators of the platforms
care about and so
it's not the same as actually being at a
particular point in a hierarchy in a
tribe or in a group
but it feels like it isn't so we we keep
behaving as though
it's real think about it now though
think about the way that people
interpret
social media clout and following i
always use this example so imagine
you're going out for dinner
and you sit down at a table and it's you
and the misses and there's a bunch of
new couples there and you've never met
them before and you sit next to someone
you're talking to them you're talking to
the husband of the wife and you're just
chatting away and they seem nice and
they go to the bathroom
and you think i'll just i'll just have a
look on instagram and see
see what they're up to see what they're
like and you go on and that person's got
a million followers immediately your
impression of them
changes dramatically because that one
million followers is a signal of a bunch
of different things you're gonna go
they've got a like a [ __ ] million
like what
what does she do like that's immediately
and you think okay
it's signaling is anything any sort of
output we're constantly looking for
different cues of
what is this person how can i find out
more information
information foragers as um
sam harris's guest from the other week
said that that is another cue
but we have socioculturally now created
an entire
uh ecosystem around that right we
understand what it means to be a person
who has a million followers
so you said before whether it's real or
not whether it puts you up the hierarchy
or not
but our interpretations of that and uh
uh own subjective rating and value of
that has made it real
whether it was or not it now is yeah
it's true
and there's a separate uh a separate
trend that i think explains that as well
it's the metrication of absolutely
everything
so for a long time you could measure
people if you knew how much money they
had that was a
that was one objective thing you could
use to rank them in a sense if that's
the way you were oriented
um and so you know like discussions of
net worth
that was one kind of discussion you
could have but socially that's more
difficult to do like
does this person have 27 real life
friends or 30 we didn't ever measure
people that way
but this metrication movement means that
beyond things like net worth
you can measure a whole lot of new
things objectively like social currency
now is measure
is measurable in an objective way so yes
i'm sitting at a table with someone that
in my head i'm valuing as a
person with 500 followers and it turns
out they have a million well there must
be something incredibly interesting or
eccentric or worth
worth knowing about them that i perhaps
don't know is it
and some of those things might be
observable right if this person's a
model
i probably got some sense of that from
sitting at the table with the person but
if this person is just
incredibly bright and interesting and i
haven't yet got that sense
and people follow him or her because of
that
just that content that kind of you know
unspools that's a fascinating thing
right and that makes me way more
interested in actually getting to know
the person
so i think some of it's real some of
it's not real um and
what's interesting about the example you
gave is is um the ambiguity in a lot of
cases like
what why what is it about you that makes
you that person
you would have gone under the radar
before the social media era began and
and we'd met at a party and there would
have been no way to quantify how
interesting you are
but now i now i can know that you're a
million you're worth a million followers
which tells me something why do you
think we're
on this move towards metricking
objectifying
making objective uh all of these
different
sort of quantifiable values why do you
think that is in the modern era
well i think it's driven by you know
we're always going to be curious about
ourselves and
we're curious curious about ourselves
relative to other people
um and there's a there's also a really
strong drive towards self-improvement
and betterment
and i think with with access to huge
amounts of data with the hardware and
the software that we need to be able to
to measure things that we couldn't
before cheaply i think we're doing that
so you know
the good example of this is measuring
sleep or exercise patterns
the idea that when i'm asleep i can see
whether i'm in deep sleep whether i'm in
rem sleep whether i'm in shallow sleep
how much deep good sleep i'm getting
each night you could do that fairly
cheaply now you couldn't do that cheaply
except if you were in a sleep lab
for decades and so that's i mean i think
that's a really big
big part of this right that um we are
now able to measure more things that i
think we've always been curious about
but it was beyond us to measure them
that's part of it i also think um
a lot of a lot of this is comparative
like you have social networks like
strava will measure your running and you
can then see how much do i run relative
to all the other people i follow on
strava
um you can you know
you if you're curious about it you can
find out where you lie on pretty much
any spectrum
you can work out your percentile ranking
for whatever you're interested in and
you can metricate it and so i think
it's just this drive to understand
ourselves better which is eternal
but we're able to do that in a now
sharper hard-edged way that we weren't
able to do before
isn't it interesting that we've found
this metricization of everything
movement
just after we've kind of moved into a
very secular society
a lot of the old traditions have been
lost uh the sort of more esoteric
side of religion has also gone
the scientific revolutions occurred
where utilitarian rational beings were
sort of praying at the altar of science
and it feels to me like this is just
another
step along the way that people's meaning
perhaps might have previously been due
to their faith
or due to their community and now that
that's been pulled apart a little bit
i don't know the name of the people that
live next door to me um
right that wouldn't have been the case
not very many years ago
so i think that perhaps in that people
trying to fill that hole i also
have this theory around personal
development that
uh the removal of god and faith from
people's lives means that they've got
broader death anxiety and that
self-development
and personal growth and especially the
longevity movement and biohacking
are all scientifically compatible ways
of denying death
well yeah but i'm going to get more life
in before it happens or i'm going to
delay the time that it does happen or
i'm going to stop it from happening at
all or i'm gonna
upload myself into the mainframe um
yeah it all seems to kind of be a
perfect storm
coalescing yeah yeah i agree with that i
think that's
that's probably true um and you do get
pushback right that um because we've
become all about objective
measurement and about scientism
i think you do see a lot of people who
who are pushing in the opposite
direction whenever the pendulum swings a
long way in one direction it's going to
swing back and so
there's there's a movement known as
retromania and it's this this kind of
love for things that are inferior from
the past
but that we crave because they are part
of a past that we we idealize
um and there's some really interesting
examples of this in in germany there's a
there's a small movement it's called
nostalgia like nostalgia without the n
australian east it's this nostalgia for
for aspects of east german life that
were inferior like
the toothpaste didn't taste as good or
the products weren't as good but there
are people who used to live
under that regime and they've become
kind of nostalgic for the way things
used to be
and there are small pockets of this all
around the world this kind of weird
backward focus not weird but this
backward focused view
that idealizes a past that was often
inferior in many respects and i think
it's
partly because of what you're suggesting
we've leached a lot of the meaning out
of life whether it's
whether it's about secularization or
i think the arts and and uh music
and and the woolly stuff the subjective
stuff that i think is
has was historically a bigger part of
the human experience
for a lot of people plays almost no role
in their lives and i think they
they miss something really critical and
uh
i totally agree with you and i do i do
think um whether it's religion or other
systems of meaning if you don't have
that
we know there's there's a
certainly there's death anxiety there's
terror management theory is this idea
that you you
reach out for a god or for some sort of
system of meaning to
explain your life especially as death
becomes more prominent we've been living
through a pandemic it's been a big part
of our experience for a year
so um yeah i totally agree i think it's
it's a
it's a really interesting trend uh
talking about the target thing
and how we're so sort of teleological as
beings
i was reading the happiness hypothesis
by john hate and i know it's not very
new but it was first time i read it and
it's awesome
um he talked about one of the reasons
why we have a shocking thought and we
can't get it out of our head
so you know you see the old lady by the
side of the road
and you just think like i wonder what it
would be like if i pushed her in
obviously you never do
but you have this thought and then you
think like oh my god that's just like
how could you
how dare you think like that this must
be something wrong with me and then he
can't stop thinking about it
and he was talking about the fact that
as soon as you set that objective out
there
what your brain does is it constantly
measures how far you are away from
reaching that objective
even if your goal is to be away from the
objective like not eat more food
a lot of the time when you're trying to
diet you're actually obsessing about
food when the next piece of food is
coming even if it's on a restricted
a restricted calorie diet and um yeah it
makes a lot of sense that
as soon as a target is set even if the
target is to decrease rather than
increase what you're doing
it causes you to actually obsess about
what is going on
a lot more and um with this channel you
know i made a big deal about hitting 100
000 subs on youtube
like there is as you said objectively no
different apart from the silver play
button that youtube sends you that's
pretty cool
um but there is objectively no
difference but like i built it up and
then sure enough the morning that i woke
up
between 99 and 101 or whatever it was
like life was still the same still put
the same socks on
still had to brush my teeth you know i
mean
yeah absolutely yeah so this idea um
it's a pretty old idea but it's a really
interesting one in psychology the ironic
monitoring model
is what what it's broadly known as and
it's this idea that
it's especially for things like dieting
cases or taboos where there's something
that you're
you're supposed to not do you're not
meant to push the lady in the road
you're you're not meant to eat chocolate
cake if you're dieting all of that sort
of stuff
but you're right the only way to know
that you're not doing that thing is to
keep comparing what you're doing to that
thing
that's the irony that's the ironic
monitoring part so you know if i say to
you now for the rest of our
discussion don't think about a white
polar bear wearing
a liverpool sweat a liverpool jersey or
something like that
it's a pretty random thought you weren't
going to think about it before but now
that i've put it there as a
kind of thing against which you're
supposed to distance yourself
you'll think about it certainly more
than you would have otherwise because
you'll be saying to yourself am i
thinking about this
um so there's quite a lot of work about
intrusive thoughts and and i think
john's theory john heights actually at
nyu which is where i am as well so
we know each other pretty well um it's
it's very it's very interesting and i
i think that's right i think it's
largely about just making sure that
you're not doing the wrong thing
what was the what was some of the most
addictive apps or
experiences that you found
um i think a lot of them are games
you've got to think about which which
experiences have the most
hooks embedded in them and so social
media and games are the two that stand
out for almost everyone
games by by design humans have loved
games forever we found games really
interesting games and stories are things
that kind of drive humans on
once you start hearing a story that's
compelling you want to know what the
outcome is once you start playing a game
you want to complete the game
and so if you're designing a game and
it's a game that you can keep updating
with new levels and new features
you can basically string people along
indefinitely it's like imagine reading
an incredibly good book
that never ends like every time you're
at the last chapter the author just
tacks on another chapter on the back
and it just keeps on spooling forever
that's that's what
the best games now that keep having new
mods and and
features added on to them alike there's
no way to kind of conquer them in a way
that you could in the 80s and 90s and
2000s early 2000s
um so i think games are a big one and
then
certainly um social media for for
obvious reasons it's got the
the variable feedback hook it's got the
goal hook
the social um i guess
etiquette hook that you've got to kind
of be on there to show your face
um the absence of stopping cues removing
the feeds the bottom of the feed all of
that sort of stuff all
all embedded there i know that world of
warcraft
is often described as the single most
addictive experience
non-non-ingestion-based you know you're
not ingesting a substance it's not a
drug
but it's an experience and as an
experience it's been described as the
most addictive experience the hardest
for people to resist
there have been something like 100
million players across time
um and by some measure half of them say
that they are
sort of obsessive about playing the game
it's v and you know i
i have a friend who um he's a game
designer himself
um and he's a professor of game design
if anyone knows about game design and
the mechanics of design it's this guy
and um
i i asked him about world of warcraft
when i was researching for the book i
said you know how do you feel about it
when you play it how does it did you
find it it works on you
and he said to me look i'm supposed to
know about everything that's out there i
teach this stuff
i have not for a minute of my life play
that game because i know it's binary
either i'm not a world of warcraft
player
or i've lost everything and and i i will
be playing for years
because i know all of all of the kind of
tricks that are embedded in it
so he's he's been very careful about it
and so i think that's probably one of
the most
one of the most difficult to resist look
at what you said at the very beginning
the people in the tech world are the
ones that have the bright lines and
they're the ones who are able to control
their cold turkey would appear is the
only way to avoid
world of warcraft are there any
psychological
tricks that you think technology hasn't
been able to utilize yet is there
something that's next on the laundry
list
for a new piece of technology to tap
into
i you know i think we often we think of
our phones
in particular as kind of a destination
point like tech has been moving in this
direction for
for many hundreds of years and now the
the outcome of that move is that we now
have phones that are incredible look
what we can do in the palm of our hands
we have access to all the information in
the world etc
all the people in the world i think
really
we're at the very beginning of this
movement that maybe began 20 or so years
ago
with the rise of social media with the
rise of smartphones
the rise of them tablets and i think
where we go from here is that
vr and ar virtual and augmented reality
tech is still
it's not that mainstream you know there
are some people who have oculus glasses
but
it still hasn't become mainstream in the
way that phones are there aren't
billions of these devices floating
around
i think part of that is this the things
you can do with that
hardware uh are still quite limited but
if you speak to people in these
industries they'll tell you
give it some time you know some of them
say two years some of them say 10 years
and they say you know the industry is
going to grow dramatically
and then it won't just be you know you
and i have having a conversation my
phone's here and it comes between us not
in a physical sense but it comes between
us because
i'm distracted by it but you're actually
going to be sitting here you and i could
sit with goggles physical goggles
between us
where we're completely immersed in a
full world we could wear haptic suits
so if we're in fights we actually feel
like we're being hit um
if we're if we're running or you know
you could even have devices that pipe
smells in eventually if this gets
sophisticated enough all five senses
maybe even tastes i don't know how it's
going to be but
once the experience becomes that
immersive all five sensors are
activated we have primitive versions of
it now but
imagine if at any moment in time you
could be exactly where you want to be
doing exactly what you want to be doing
you know it's
it's snowy here in connecticut i want to
be on a beach in greece right now
i can have the very next best thing to
actually being there why would i sit
here and do my work
when i could do that why would i sit
here having conversations with
say a group of people if i'm not that
interested in that conversation and
instead i could talk to
ai versions of you know the five most
interesting people in history
yeah they're using that what is it lpt3
or whatever it's called
right exactly um so that's that's where
i think we're going that's the
difference
of extent rather than a qualitative
difference i don't think that's
something completely different from what
we have now it's just a much more
effective way of
of again siloing us making us you know
unique individuals it's a little bit
like like the the book and the
film ready player one and now ready
player two by ernest cline
it's just taking that and making parts
of it real it's the delivery mechanism
right was it was it your book or someone
else's where
i read about the upper bound on being
able to change people's opinions
through a phone versus through vr and
there was something to do with
um people's paper usage meant that they
had a long-term
different view of um
tree felling do you see this have you
seen this no
well it wasn't it wasn't my book cool
yeah so so basically it was just
as you said there um as you make the
experience more immersive
the degree to which you can influence
behavior
both in the experience and then after
the experience
let's think about the levels
of extremism and um
partisanship that we're seeing from a
seven inch by two inch black square
that basically can only do sound and
light
that's in our hand like let's switch
that around to a fully immersive
experience where you can't tell the
difference between
like that's going to be
there's going to be some really big
changes that need to be made and i
i get what you mean that there's a
maximum number of psychological
hooks but the depth with which you can
get the hooks into it
changes as the platform as the platform
increases
that's a really good way of expressing
it i think that's exactly right i i can
tell you i
i gave it a talk about this at a
conference
about three years ago and at the
conference they had
this vr demonstration so i'm there
speaking about the ills of tech
and then there's a vr demonstration i
was like i should probably check out the
competition here
so i went and did this experience it was
eight minutes long
it involved a haptic suit so i could
feel like
pressure and it was a ghostbusters
experience
i was never a huge ghostbusters fan i
didn't i've watched the
movies maybe once um
but it was like the most incredible
eight minutes
you're in new york city you're in the
top of the building you're chasing a
ghost you have this thing that acts as
like a whatever
the ray is that you're shooting uh the
ghosts go through you and the haptic
suit compresses so it feels like they're
actually
i didn't know that ghost could actually
influence you it shouldn't feel them but
in this
little world you could and i remember
thinking
that was so much fun like i like video
games
i play some i've never had that much fun
that eight minutes was just like so rich
and if you'd said to me you can forego
eating
and sleeping and for 24 hours we will
we'll expand this eight minute
experience to 24 hours
100 i would say yes but imagine if
that's
available for the rest of your life
that's it really scared me a little bit
because i realized just how deep those
hooks were
and i'm a guy who's really thoughtful
about this right if anyone's going to
push back it's me and i was like yep
sign me up i'm done i'm good
that's exactly what we said at the
beginning the difference between what's
happening behind what we can see
objectively within the programming
objectively what your goals are
but then the experience what the
phenomenal phenomenology of that's like
i went to dot dot dot in london
which was the world's first ar
vr and
holographics jeff wayne's war of the
worlds experience
oh wow so i had uh the world's first phd
in immersive storytelling on the show
about a year ago sarah dr sarah jones
and um she said you need to go to this
thing
it's the most advanced technology for
augmented reality and everything
and um if you've ever been to edinburgh
dungeons or a sort of a tour
where there's actors and they're
interacting with you so
dude you arrive at this place that
they've created
and for two hours from the moment that
you step in there
actors are interacting with you and
walking you through
um the streets of london and the posters
are up and it's you in a small little
group in there
and then they'll pass you on to another
person and then you're in a boat
and at each different stage this one was
augmented reality
and you're seeing all of these things
moving around then right get into this
huge big hall
and put the headset on and the haptic
feedback thing and you're moving around
and it was for
two hours including a break in a bar a
virtual reality bar
in the middle of it and then you kept on
going i it was
the the date that i went with was awful
um but the experience was fantastic
so i kind of didn't really care that i'd
paid for her because i was at least
worth double the money so it kind of
doesn't matter
um but dude it was
outrageous oh man you would it's such a
shame because it extended it
um i would have gone again but they
extended it and then covered happened
sir
i haven't had the chance but yeah it was
um and that like
this the sad part about it is and i wish
that this wasn't the case i often get
criticized for kind of being from some
of my friends that are big into
tech and crypto and stuff like that for
kind of being a bit of a doomsayer
around this i've been a massive fan of
your work i've been a massive fan of
chris dan harris and the center for
humane technology and stuff like that
tristan was on sam's show like four
years ago or something and i went fully
down the rabbit hole as soon as that
happened
i get criticized for being this
doomsayer about it
and i wish i wish that i could have this
untarnished hope for the future because
this stuff's
like sick like it was so much fun
and imagine here's my thing that i
really want to have happen so clubhouse
is big at the moment
imagine a vr clubhouse where
all of the audience can sit in a room
and they can be front and center
watching
naval rava can't talk to elon musk and
joe rogan
and and brett weinstein or something
like that and you can sit there and you
can have a beer
or you can have a some popcorn in the
comfort of your own house
watching them go like that's just
front row seat to the best stuff on the
internet
but i can't because of my fears around
it and because of the challenges that
i've come up against with regards to my
tech use
i i can't have this like unburnished
hope for it i just i have fear
yeah i i wrestle with that all the time
um what you're saying makes
makes a lot of sense and and resonates
with my sense too
i i think people often assume that i'm
going to be
a complete doomsayer but i'm going to
come on and say you've got to go
hardline
kids shouldn't be around screens you
know we should go back to the 1950s and
i'm not like that
i think i'm a little bit more pragmatic
than that because
i think the the reason we're even having
these conversations is because there is
so much that is great about screens and
tech
if they if they weren't we would have
just said hey this is crap let's just
toss it out before it becomes anything
but it's become successful and it's
changed our lives because there is so
much it has so much to offer
i think the path we've taken is broken
the ad based model where you say you'll
make more money as a business and you'll
not just make more money you'll be one
of the biggest businesses that's ever
been
you know that that we've ever known by
selling more ads
obviously the only way you sell ads is
by having people to view those ads and
buy stuff
so that's that model is broken so there
are certainly things we can fix about
the the way the world is now the screen
based world
um but i think for for individual
consumers like you like me like lots of
other people we can take a lot of the
good
like if that happens if what you just
described this kind of vr version of
clubhouse happens
you could go once a week choose the best
show the way you might
when i was in new york city maybe 10
years ago
there was a time where once a week i
would go and see a live band it was
amazing i could have done it every night
but i said to myself
do it once a week i could have developed
a kind of unhealthy obsession and i
would have been out every night and lost
all my money and
uh it wasn't cheap um but it was a lot
of fun
you could do that here right you could
take the best of that you could pick one
conversation a week i know it's it's
hard sometimes to plan and stuff because
it happens
on the spur of the moment but you know
i'm gonna go watch one of these a week
and have a beer while i'm watching that
there are ways to curate your life so
you get the best from these forms of
tech without having to
just accept the bad stuff that comes
along with them and i think that's the
key goal here that's certainly my goal
i don't want to turn my back on tech i
want to embrace it fully
but in embracing it recognize what it's
doing that's negative and then try to
excise as much of that negative stuff
that baggage that crap that distances me
from the people i love
that makes it hard for me to get work
done while also enjoying the fact that
hey there are good things about
clubhouse and twitter and instagram and
snapchat and
facebook and whatever else i don't want
to be a luddite i just want
i want to get as much of the good stuff
without the bad what are some of the
tactics that you use to ensure that
happens in your own life
the first thing is knowing what is the
good stuff and what is the bad stuff
you know uh you do an audit ask yourself
what
about my tech use brings me benefit
utility
joy um or makes me feel a sense of awe
whatever those things are do more of
that and
there's there's a company that um it
would interrupt people as they were
using their screens i had to opt into
this and it would say what are you using
now
it obviously knew that and how do you
feel about it
are you happy or are you sad and you'd
learn something about which things
people were doing on their screens
brought them joy and which things didn't
you could do an individual version of
that i know that much of the time
i'm um especially after i'm finished
playing a game or after i've been on
social media for a long time
i don't feel great about it google maps
as a utility
it's like one of the greatest things
that was ever developed that part of
tech the utility part that
taking things that used to be time
consuming that used to get in the way of
calendars reminders
brilliant i'm all for that stuff i'm
never going to get addicted to my
calendar
but it's going to only make my life
better it's going to save me time for
the things that really matter so that
i'm a very big utility tech person
that's why tech was originally invented
it wasn't invented to come between
people it was invented to let you get
the stuff that was annoying done fast so
that you could then have time with
people
so i think understanding better what are
the things that and also what are the
hooks that get you
i know which stuff gets me and i know if
a program has those hooks in it it's
probably going to be hard for me to
resist
the same way my friend said world of
warcraft not even going to go near it i
know i'm in trouble
and from there you can you can install
systems like just
decide what you want to do either you
can use software that's going to get you
after a certain number of hours or
you're going to have hard and fast rules
the dinner rule is one that we do have
in my family i have two little kids my
wife and i we do not use screens around
them
they watch a bit of tv but they
certainly don't use phones or tablets
um so yeah it's
you don't have to be too hard-line about
it but i think the knowledge the
understanding of what drives you and
what what makes you happier and brings
you well-being is important and then
um knowing what kinds of things you can
do to short-circuit the the hooks
you know on your phone turning off
notifications making the phone grayscale
if you're one of those people um that
stuff's really effective
so try it out just be an experimentalist
yeah i've been through a lot of these in
an effort to curb my
phone use i've got two different devices
one of them has social media on but it's
only wi-fi
the other one has my messaging on but is
gprs so it means i can actually use that
out and about
but my twitter and instagram and all
that sort of stuff stays on that phone
similarly it's portioned off so that the
phone i need to do my morning routine
meditation and
such like it's like that no phone in the
bedroom no phones after
uh eight o'clock at night or before
midday so like
i'm intermittent fasting with my device
and creating this bizarre system of
rules and structures
it makes me feel um oddly quite
comforted uh for you to say
that the people who have the best
techies have this ridiculous sort of
tom and jerry style mousetrap
construction
of their lives to be able to put it
together
because it makes me feel less sad
because that's like me with the pulley
and like the the chair leg turned upside
down and a fork and a toaster on top of
it like that's me that's
the way that i've had to go and yeah i
um for anyone that's listening that
wants to try
some strategies put the charger for your
phone
now outside of your bedroom just put it
in the kitchen or the living room or
even the hallway outside of your
your room if you need to be able to hear
it um it means that you're not tempted
to roll over and use it on a night time
it means that you don't use it first
thing when you wake up
by a sunrise alarm clock or a radio
alarm clock or anything else they've
been around for like forever
um just buy one of those replace it
means that you've got
even just that change um always put your
phone in the boot of your car
uh always make sure because it stops you
from the temptation of using it while
you're driving and
give yourself some start times and end
times and intermittent fast with your
phone
that does in my opinion like and
notifications notifications off
i mean group chats yeah someone
that isn't you said something not about
you to someone else that isn't you
and you were told about it come on
there was a there was a cat that went
missing on my street
we have a street we have we have like a
holiday party on my street
so you know once a year this is what
this this list is supposed to be
once a year telling everyone whose house
we're going to and who's bringing the
beer and all of that stuff
i got 78 emails about a missing cat that
was found
by the third email and the other 75
emails were a celebrate sorry texts were
a celebration of the fact
that the the cat had been found i'm glad
the cat's been found
but we only all need to celebrate
collectively i'm all with you on taking
those notifications off
we're birds of a feather there what
about um cliffhangers why are
cliffhangers so effective
because um as a species we're
completionists the same reason that we
keep
approaching a goal until we reach the
goal we want to know the end of the
story
um we don't like things half completed
it's
it's just kind of embedded in us we
don't like to leave things half done
um it feels unfulfilled uh
it feels like we've wasted time there's
some cost part of it as well that we
feel like we've invested some time and
energy into this thing we want to know
how we want to see it through so people
will read a bad book
they'll get halfway through and say i'm
hating this but i should finish
because otherwise what was that first
half for i wasted all that time which
makes no sense you should just stop the
minute you hate the book
and that's that's how cliffhangers work
as well they uh they
they not only do you want to finish the
thing but if it's well done
it's something you actually want to find
out so like a well-written tv show you
get to the
you know five minutes before the end
then appears the cliffhanger so you'll
watch the next episode of the
that follows it um it's incredibly
effective
that's why cliffhangers are so effective
because we don't like leaving goals
uncompleted or
really anything uncompleted the zygonic
effect is a hell of a drug
it is exactly uh the book's been out for
a while
like has there been anything new that
you've come across like if you were to
tackle
a chapter that synthesizes some of the
most interesting stuff since it's been
out
uh are there any things that you would
put in there
yeah there's a huge amount the book
would be very different if i wrote it
today
i started writing it in 2014 which is a
very long time ago
in fact when i tried to sell the rights
to the book i had a bit of trouble
because
there was a bit of pushback from people
saying this is a storm and a tea cup no
one cares about this
like no one's worried about screen news
look at you with your cassandra complex
adam
right exactly like what's wrong with you
um well
let's write another book about how great
tech is we don't need one that says it's
bad
um and they were wrong because as i was
writing the book
things started to shift and by the time
the book came out in 2017 things had
well and truly shifted um i would spend
more time writing about
so the the subtitle of the book is um
the rise of addictive technology and the
business of keeping us hooked
the business of keeping us hooked i
struggled to get behind the curtain
because not many people inside these big
companies were talking about what was
going on
now since the book came out beginning
about six months after the book came out
there were a whole lot of exposed
tell-alls and i wish i could have
included some of that but
i i even arranged an interview to speak
to someone from one of these large
companies in la
flew across the country landed in l.a
and he ghosted me
so that's how hard it was to get behind
the curtain in 2015.
so things have changed so i would tack
on some of that
i would uh what else would i do um
i i probably want to talk more about vr
and ar than i did because they've come a
long way
um i i'd talk about it briefly for like
a couple of pages
but i didn't have much more to say about
it at that point so there are a few
things
um i you know early on i had a lot of
pushback from people who said
how do you know these aren't just great
products like the definition of a great
product is one that people can't stop
using because they like it they get
great benefit from it
and maybe it's just these companies are
great are the greatest product
developers of all time
they just know more about humans than
any other other company and then
at the end of 2017 sean parker one of
the early investors in facebook
came out and said oh we've known that
this is terrible for a long time
basically we we don't care or we didn't
care
i feel bad about it now we knew we were
robbing you of your time your attention
one of his friends said to him i'm not
going to use this and he said oh you
will and we're going to get you
i mean this is a guy who's talking about
how how people inside
facebook's inner circle were talking in
2004 five six
and they knew exactly what they were
doing it was predatory and so i put more
of that in the book as well
i think that's one of the things that i
often try and get across when i have
this conversation with people for the
first time so
the first touch of the red pill the
digital red pill um
i try and put across that it is an
unfair fight by a magnitude that you
can't understand
there are thousands of data analysts
some of the most powerful algorithms on
the planet
and several tens of billions of dollars
behind every single swiping press
of your thumb yeah and you just think
that you're dancing through the
daisy field that is facebook or tinder
or tiktok
but it's not it is very very curated i
was told
recently that apps
and websites specifically are able to
detect someone's level of ambient
anxiety
just through the movement of their mouse
and the way that they're moving around
on the screen
that they've been able to infer if
someone's feeling a little bit more
anxious and that means that you can
perhaps tell oh well this person might
be
more susceptible to a chocolate ad or
this person might actually need
an alcohol add um because the
the movement of the mouse is in a
particular fashion which has been
associated with other people in anxious
states
if it's not true it will be so that's
that's how most of this stuff works
you know it's it sounds interesting it
sounds plausible whether it's been
operationalized as another question
but it sounds absolutely like if it's
not happening it's one step from where
we are and it shouldn't be that hard to
implement
right as long as you can gather the data
and process the data i know
some researchers at nyu have done a lot
of work on what you can tell about
people based on how they're moving a
mouse so i'm sure that's true
you can tell about indecision for
example which makes sense
right if you're moving a mouse the pace
at which you move the acceleration if i
want to go from here to here and i go
there's no indecision i'm decisive i
know exactly what i want to do
if i'm wavering and i'm kind of like you
can you you may not recognize that as a
person using the tool
but it's absolutely written in every
movement you make and and
if you have the data you have the
coordinates all you need is the x and
the y
you can say this person's a little bit
unsure and then you can make decisions
on the basis of that
i totally believe it what are the
implications around
childhood development and using these
devices have you looked at that
i have we don't really know um and and
part of the reason we don't really know
is
the tech is fairly young the research on
the tech is even younger
so in 2007 when apple introduced the
iphone the first gen
there were no researchers doing work on
this it took us a few years to catch on
which means that we've never really had
kids who were born into the phone world
and and very few kids get a phone when
they're born you know like as a four
year four month old you're not using a
phone yet
you shouldn't be um and so it makes it
difficult to know exactly what it's
doing to
especially infant development toddler
development
there are a few things a few hints
though one of the hints is that if you
are if all of your social experiences
are mediated through a phone
you get very poor feedback low fidelity
feedback that takes a long time to reach
you so everything you do on a phone if
you're speaking to someone else or on a
screen
is lower fidelity contains less
information and it's it's less rich it's
poor information
so if i'm a kid and i'm in a room with
another kid
i take that kid's toy the kid bops me on
the head
and i'm like oh that didn't work out so
well i shouldn't take the kid's toy
or i should but i should make sure that
i'm aware that that's going to upset
the other kid you learn that really fast
by doing
you learn it much more slowly if you're
trying to work out like what
what's the social effect of my actions
through a screen
um you just think about bullying on on
social media the kind of bullying that
goes on on social media wouldn't happen
in
person most of those bullies would not
be able to do what they do
staring into the face of the person into
the eyes of the person they're upsetting
it's just that's not how humans work
but if you distance us give us social
distance psychological distance we'll do
all sorts of terrible things
there's research on that going back to
the the 40s 50s and 60s
so um i think that's one big effect that
kids are going to be socialized more
slowly to the extent they spend time
behind screens
they may not be fully socialized at all
in certain respects
one of the things we learned to do by
being in the presence of other people is
we learn to distinguish subtle emotional
changes especially facial expressions so
the difference between
frustration fear anger sadness
in facial expressions as adults most of
us can do that effortlessly
i can tell what someone else is thinking
kids need to learn that
they need it takes a bit of time for
them to get there and if you're
looking through a screen the whole time
you know i have the sense that i'm
you and i have eye contact right now but
we're looking at a screen and we're
looking at a
camera it's not quite the same as
actually looking at a person's eyes
directly
so um i think a lot of that means that
kids are going to be developed
developing a little bit more slowly and
maybe some of the faculties won't
fully emerge until they have more
face-to-face experience with other
people
i remember i was out for dinner in dubai
in november with a young couple and they
had the
kid and when the i think he must have
been about
three when or four and when he was
getting a little bit unruly
uh one of them would just get the phone
out and put youtube on and just
plop youtube in front of the kid and i
was i remember thinking at the time i
was like well
from my perspective i wanted a quite
peaceful meal so it's quite nice for me
but i wonder what that's doing to the
child's development like what does it
tell us during our most formative most
developmental years
that when you face discomfort
or hardship you can
anaesthetize that with a screen
right yeah exactly
and and this is as as a parent of two
young kids
i i'm constantly faced with that that
question right it's always easier to
give your child the phone
it's always going to be easier it's an
incredible tool it's an amazing pacifier
um but that's that's the question in the
long run if we're constantly using this
pacifier you teach your kid
that there's no such thing as boredom
boredom should not be tolerated for even
a minute
your own thoughts are something to be
afraid of you know the the moment when
you are sitting there just
inhabiting your own headspace that
that's a problem that the only way to
deal with it is to medicate it with a
screen
that's problematic the idea that sitting
at a table
is such a hardship that there needs to
be a way to deal with it that's way more
entertaining like visiting entertainment
upon a young brain
because the act of sitting at a table is
just too unpleasant that's problematic
too
so um you know
i i became much more kind of i became
much less hard-line when i became a
parent because i know
how hard it is especially with kids um
to to manage a lot of this stuff
um but also obviously i'm very mindful
about it i don't want to
i don't want to do something that will
affect my kids in a way that
makes them less happy and healthy um but
these are all the things that i think
about as well i think it's it's a big
part of it
whose job is it to fix this problem like
is it
educational is it policy-wise does it
need to come top down is it cultural
do we need new language around this is
it bottom-up
both i think it's both i think we all as
individuals have some responsibility
that's the bottom-up part
um and and the good news is in the last
as i've seen i've tracked it from 2014
at seven years now
there is much more bottom-up pressure on
tech companies
whether it was because of cambridge
analytica privacy concerns whether it's
about now the
the rise of awareness about how tech
companies are behaving
and the hooks they're embedding in these
programs we're certainly much smarter
and savvier about
all that this stuff and so that's that's
i think a good thing so there is
bottom-up pressure
um but i think some of it has to come
also from from governments from
legislation from policy making a lot of
people bristle at that
they don't like the idea of the
government intervening but the
government intervenes on so many things
that i think
um i i am not opposed to it if we can
find the right kinds of interventions
and certainly there are testing grounds
around the world in east asia there's a
lot of this
in parts of western europe and northern
europe this is starting to happen as
well
where they're starting to introduce
small bits of legislation it's very
piecemeal
but the legislation is is designed to
improve the experience of
the end user like in france for example
if you have a company that's got more
than 50 employees
the the um the company needs to have a
written charter that explains how those
employees
will be protected from email after hours
so what will the company do with batch
emails yeah it's i think it's a good
maybe it's not exactly the right move
the details might not be right
but the idea of having companies say you
know what
i i guess we don't need to send you
emails at 2am so what we're going to do
is batch them and then when you wake up
at
7 00 a.m we will release a tranche of
emails that have been stored overnight
that kind of thing or vacation policies
like
you know when you go on vacation instead
of just sending the email to you anyway
we're going to batch them we're going to
hold them or even better there are some
companies in germany now that are just
deleting those emails
so if i'm on vacation you email me
you'll get a response that says adam's
on vacation
you can email that same email again when
he gets back after this date
or we can just if you send a reply that
says forward we'll send it to someone
else who can help in
in his absence so i on vacation don't
even know that you've emailed me
because if i know that that destroys my
vacation to have to keep checking those
emails
so whatever my inbox looked like when i
left for that vacation it looks like
when i get back
so there are these these kinds of small
small changes
that i think have a pretty big effect on
well-being some of them driven by
legislation
i wonder whether all of this is worth i
wonder whether there'll be a tool
um i'm gonna guess there probably will
be someone will tell us in the comments
kind of like schedule send but schedule
receive so
not just an out of office but actually a
dam that you can place
on the other side of you between you and
your inbox
and it can just allow everything to to
build up
and it means that you don't need to
concern yourself and there's no
notifications and then it can release it
um yeah i wonder as well i mean we've
got
laws around the minimum age that
children can drink at
and the children can have sex at um and
that's because they're
not given the right amount of agency to
be able to make decisions on their own
now you could argue that
the effect of a couple of years of phone
use
could be as detrimental or perhaps more
detrimental in different ways to
alcohol and substance abuse um i
i don't know whether that's quite true
but it's definitely in the same sort of
paradigm
so yeah it makes it makes complete sense
i think
you're right legislation we're
definitely seeing more sort of cultural
talk around it
and as that begins to get more and more
nuanced the problem obviously is that
the leviathan the goliath slow-moving
slumping
monster that is government and policy is
always going to be playing
so much catch-up um yeah here's another
thing actually as well so
i have a a theory around covid and the
fact that we were delivered such a
piss-weak pathogen as our first modern
era
virus that it almost inoculated us in a
systemic way
culturally we understand in the modern
era what it means to have a virus
we understand what it means to have
global travel but also need to shut it
down we know what ppe is we know what
social distancing is all of that sort of
stuff and i wonder if
um it's actually going to be a benefit
for us as a civilization because if the
next one happens in 100 years time
and the mortality of that is 5x what
kovid was we will be ready for it i
wonder if
the introduction by tech companies of
these platforms at this stage
with the glass ceiling that we have on
the level of interaction actually means
that we're going to have the policies
the culture maybe even sort of the
education to be able to deal with when
ar
and vr arrive because some of the
psychological hooks will
will maybe be inoculated against them
what do you what your thoughts on
on that uh yeah
it's um it's possible i that that's why
i was speaking about ar and vr which i
think is the the next level
if we can manage to cope with these
devices then i think we're in a much
better place to cope with
with headsets and things like that so i
think i think that's right
um it's interesting you say in a hundred
years you know there was a pandemic
hundred years ago and it was very
damaging and yet we didn't learn a damn
thing from it
so i i think the the half-life is
is small um is is short it's brief
for another pandemic i hope this doesn't
happen but if there were another
pandemic and it
were shortly after this one then sure
we've learned a lot about ppe and
vaccinations and social distancing and
all that sort of stuff and
masks whatever but humans have a short
memory
um we're not we're not going to remember
this for that long and a lot of the
podcasts i've done recently have been
about this this new normal idea like
what's changed forever and what hasn't
are we still going to be working from
home
in two years five years 10 years 15
years
i think a lot of things are going to go
back to the way they were that's
happened after almost every crisis that
humans have ever faced
most things the vast majority of things
go back largely to the way they were
um and i think that's going to happen
here as well i know that's not about
screens and tech you know
it was an interesting it was an
interesting question you asked or
interesting idea you posed you mentioned
over email that you're working on
something new how much of
what your current time is taking up
doing can you tell us
um you mean you want me to tell you what
i'm working on yeah
yes i just didn't know if it was super
super duper secret
it's not super duper secret um i'm
working on a new project uh
it's it's a third book and it's about
getting unstuck
so we think of being stuck as um and
it's a kind of natural extension of some
of the other work i've done but we think
of being stuck as a kind of glitch
um and it's it feels very personal when
you're stuck like i don't know what why
is this happening to me i don't know
what to do about it could be stuck in
relationships in work
in any kind of change you want to make
in your life
but it's a feature so if you look at
success and you look at how people
succeed
there are almost no stories where there
wasn't
just a string of sticking points and so
some people overcome them some don't
some businesses overcome them some don't
some governments overcome them some
don't
some species overcome them some don't
and the question is what are the kind of
tools and tricks you can define like
what can you extract from all of this to
learn
you are going to be stuck we're all
going to be stuck at some point we
collectively have been stuck for a year
in some respects physically and
otherwise
so what can we do to become more
resilient to these sticking points
and when they arrive how do we overcome
them more quickly and more effectively
so that they become a feature of our
lives rather than this like
calamitous quake there's this term this
this guy bruce filer uses which i love
he says
on average we will experience i think
it's something like between
five and ten life quakes through the
lifespan
and a life quake is just one of those
colossal events we have a lot of small
changes in our lives
but a life quake will be a really big
event that will really shape the
foundations of your life
we we always experience those as just
this calamity
like i don't even know what i'm going to
do now and that'll they'll be there
every one of us will face them so the
question is how can we be more resilient
how can we prepare for them a little bit
more effectively
so that's what i'm working on how long
is it going to be do you think before
it's uh i'm writing it now
um i i would guess
2023 to be conservative about it
um it's the the final manuscript is due
in 2022 but there's a production lag and
all of that i'd say 2023
but i'm not sure we'll see exciting man
i'm really really excited i will be
100 now that i've got your email i'll be
100 reaching out to uh
to get you back on i don't mind thank
you uh it's been a long time coming
we've been talking about doing this for
a long time i'm very very glad that
we've gone to talk about this today i
think
it really is one of the most important
conversations
that everybody needs to understand uh
and i appreciate the work that you did
and the cassandra complex that you must
have felt
um after writing it in 2000 starting in
2014 and then
and then coming back as the prophecy has
returned if people want to sort of keep
updated
with what you're doing and maybe know
when the new books out was best for them
to go um
just search for my name on google you'll
find me i've got my academic website at
nyu and then i've got my personal
website which has all the
updates on books and things like that
amazing thank you very much man
thanks for having me
[Music]
you